[Music]
christmas time in Berlin a time for
glittering lights good cheer and winter
fun everyone's prepared for the
festivities except me a Christmas tree
would help the site five look like
connects me with a nearest Christmas
tree farmer I can then order the tree I
want from him directly and it will be
delivered but I want to pay him a
personal visit matthias young has
received around 150 orders from the
website so far he still cuts down up to
70,000 trees every Christmas season for
the tree vendors in the Berlin region
that sounds like a lot to me but he says
he's trying to become even more
eco-friendly but what is even tall as
envoy muezzin said Diana we've had
global gap certification for three years
global gap is an international
sustainability certificate in our the
paper we are not supposed to use too
much pesticide employees have to be paid
fairly and have the right work clothes
who put part film the this certification
is important these days and we're glad
to have it folks photography fishing
tomorrow we also only cut the trees down
when they've been ordered next year we
plant trees in their place so it's
sustainable it's not hard
[Music]
that's the tree I'll be getting in the
mail I'm quite happy with it but I still
want to hear more on how Matthias keeps
his business environmentally sound as it
turns out he gets by with a little help
from his friends booya me Jesus watch
over here we have Shropshire sheep the
oath it's a great from England went
website offers on top of a [ __ ] nothing
drops your sheep or a well-known breed
for one specific characteristic people
they graze on plots like this but they
don't eat the Christmas trees play the
weeds and then we don't need to use weed
killers who kind of comes with Muslims
my tree cost me thirty four euros but I
already paid for it online now I'm
leaving it in good hands my next stop a
green Advent market where I meet mark
van Bourke creator of the vibe detect
website finally I've discovered some
eco-friendly class and copper Christmas
tree decorations they've been really
hard to find
but of course I'm curious to hear from
mark house eco-friendly Christmas tree
website is progressing so how do you
choose your farmers I've chosen farmers
based on a regional Network I really
care about buying local and so because
of that I wanted to have a local option
for everybody in Germany and so we have
farmers in think it's 10 states now and
each of them has been vetted we visited
them three four times they have the
quality standards that would we expect
than we need and this regionality makes
it more sustainable this regionality
makes it much more sustainable people
care about whether tree is coming from
so we provide a lot of transparency as
well you select the farmer actually that
you're choosing to buy from and so yeah
it's a lot more environmentally friendly
there's a lot lower shorter distances
between the farm and the customer which
is very different from the normal
systems how Christmas trees are
delivered
[Music]
a sustainable Christmas takes work to
put together even with all the help I've
gotten so far but I still have a bit of
time left till the holidays by then I'll
hopefully have my eco-friendly tree
looking very Merry indeed
[Music]